similar parts of the brain there's a lot
of overlap in how we process both
visceral disgust and and moral disgust
psychopaths they needless to say they're
these cold-blooded killers are greatly
over-represented in many of our
high-security jails and these
individuals show damage to many of the
same circuits that are involved in
disgust another group of individuals
although they're not predatory but
people with Huntington's disease it also
damages some of the circuits that are
involved in disgust people with
Huntington's disease are tend not to be
empathetic and they think that this is
related to these circuits being damaged
and they're almost unique and that they
experience almost no visceral disgust
whatsoever so somebody with hundreds
dints disease for example would think
nothing of picking up pcs with their
bare hands so there is this or very
interesting interrelationship at least
in the brain between visceral and moral
disgust a little known fact is that
conservatives are more disgust sensitive
there's a huge variation across
populations and how disgust sensitive
people are there's actually standardized
scales that measure for example the
questionnaire you fill out and will ask
you questions about like how revolted
you would be if you stepped on dog poop
or you know if you saw a cockroach on
pizza or a dirty toilet and as a result
of filling out these questionnaires
they've been able to look to see if
there's parallels between how disgust
sensitive someone is and how
conservative they are and indeed there
is a correlation and probably the reason
for that is because again the
Conservatives if you kind of really
break down their belief systems they
tend to have
conservative sexual values so for
example you know concepts like virginity
pleasures or you know ideas that they're
fond of that they also tend to be more
opposed immigration and foreigners are
leading source at least in centuries
past foreigners were a leading source of
exotic germs for which we had no natural
defenses so that's it's speculated that
that could be another factor behind why
people who are more conservative in
their political ideology why they tend
to be opposed to to immigration
conservatives also tend to be very
tradition downed they tend to be a
little bit more rigid about following
religious doctrine and again a lot of
religious practice practices may help to
protect against infection so that's the
leading theory as to why you see this
association but in general even in large
survey studies they thought they've
shown this link between germophobia and
xenophobia so for example there was a
paper actually it's about to be
published and I think they looked at two
thousand Danes and twelve hundred
Americans representative samples from
both countries and they found that that
opposition to immigration increased
inter direct proportion to the disgust
sensitivity of the individual another
group did a study of 25,000 Americans
the study was done at the time of the
2008 presidential election between John
McCain a more conservative candidate of
course and and Barack Obama and they
found that the more discussed sensitive
the person the more likely they would
vote for John McCain and they actually
showed the proportion of
that went McCain in each state it was
based on like the average disgust
sensitivity of the state based on
individual respondents to the survey